Our brains are cunningly evolved
cunningly designed to make life easier
for us and many ways that it makes life
easier for us.
But one of them is that it,
it gives us over simplified versions of,
of,
of what we're doing.
Uh,
uh,
this is a set of tricks which has been a
sort of reinvented by software
engineers.
Your desktop is a pretty good case of
it.
We have these,
you know,
little little yellow files that can be
moved around with click and drag and,
and things get put here and there.
And this is called the user illusion and
it is a losery to some degree,
but of course it's a very benign
illusion.
It's really,
really,
uh,
it's a helpful way of organizing a lot
of complexity.
We don't need to know all those details.
We just need to know how to achieve
certain effects.
And basically our brain does the same
thing and has,
has been doing it for Millennia.
Uh,
it's got its evolved,
some sort of internal signposts that are
a good shorthand for things that,
that we can do everywhere we look.
There's things we can do.
We don't know how we do them.
Uh,
we're,
we're completely cut off from,
from the process.
If,
if I say,
um,
uh,
you know,
give me the first line of limerick
makeup,
the first line of a limit,
well,
you know,
give me a few seconds and you'll come up
with two or three.
How'd you do that?
You don't know.
The words just come sort of bubbling up
and you don't have any insight into the
sort of subterranean unconscious
processes that generates that particular
district.
You may have a little insight,
but not much.
And it's,
there's a very sharp limit to the depth
that we as conscious agents can probe
our own activities.
And this,
uh,
this,
sort of superficial,
uh,
access that we have to what's going on.
That's what consciousness is.
Now when I say,
well,
who's this?
We,
who's got this access?
That's itself part of the illusion
because there isn't a sort of boss,
uh,
part of the brain that's sitting there,
with this limited access that itself is,
uh,
is,
is part of the illusion,
but it is,
is a bunch of different subsystems which
have,
uh,
varying access,
the varying things,
and that conspire in a sort of
competitive way to,
to execute whatever projects it is that
their,
uh,
in their sort of mindless way.